Thank you.
I'm just hanging out, I'm just hanging out, of course, you're here, so there's, you
know, someone does want to listen.
Yeah, just looking to see if I had an exchange, I had an exchange, I had an exchange, I had an exchange online with someone, and it just brought to mind the...
I don't know, the bigger picture that we've been talking about, and so I wanted to run
a space. And also, there's a series of books, particularly I think is a great example of
what I wanted to talk about. So, we'll see who, if anyone else shows up.
You know, if you just start a space and you're still waiting for more people, it's not that
I don't want to talk until there are more people here, it's that if I do and other people
show up, then they'll miss what I said and I end up repeating myself or forgetting to
repeat myself. And both of them can lead to poor communication. Anyhow, this great series
books. I'll start with that by saying Dungeon Crawler Carl series. I listen to them on audio
book. I'm not much of a reader. I was a reader, but I'm also dyslexic and I fought through it
for years and it gets more difficult as you get older, at least in my experience. So I read
a lot of summaries. I do a lot of skimming, but I don't read in depth fantasy for enjoyment
anymore. I listen to audio books and this series. Not every writer has, in English, ideally,
anyone who writes in English, you should be writing as if your work is going to be read aloud. Because
English was a language that, for most of its history, was always read aloud. And when people
first started reading to themselves quietly, everyone thought they were strange. I forget
exactly the name of the individual, but there's actually a first individual who was noted as
reading privately quietly to himself. And he's recorded in history because of how strange it was at the
time. All reading was done out loud and in the presence of other people. A truly good writer in English
who will always write for, or has a style that allows them to write well for their work to be read
out loud, performed. And Matt Dinneman, he has that gift. I don't think he has worked, I don't know,
he might have spent a lot of time working to be able to write in that particular way. But generally
speaking, it's just certain people have a natural predisposition to writing that way. And he has a
narrator, Jeff Hayes, who's the best audiobook narrator there is, in my opinion. And the series is called
Dungeon Crawler Carl. And it's like, it's fiction, it's absurdist fiction, science fiction type stuff.
It's not everyone's cup of tea. It's mostly, you know, until recently, mostly young men,
or men in general, read that genre of literature that he writes for. And, you know, it actually
originally was, I think the demographic was primarily autistic. When I first started listening to Lit RPG,
Audible started recommending books on how to live with autism. Now, there's nothing wrong with being
autistic. I think that it's a little disrespectful to autistic people that everyone assumes that,
right? They just, like, it's, it's sort of in vogue for people, particularly smart people to
talk about their autistic traits. I think it's, it's disrespectful to people who are actually
autistic. A lot of people have some autistic traits. It's not the same thing.
And so when I started getting those books, I was like, well, what's happening? But it's because
that was the demographic that the books were generally written for at that time. Now, because of the
success of this one author, the genre is opening up and becoming very popular because of the audiobooks
specifically. So it's really an experience. I think it's, there's very few opportunities that a person has in
their life to, like, be there when something new happens and, like, when something memorable happens,
like, the, the first best of, of, of anything, right? And this, this is, this guy's books, this series,
again, not everyone's cup of tea, but they're clearly going to be remembered as the best audiobooks of all
time, without a question, without any doubt in my mind. Uh, but it's apropos to, um,
the, the topic that I, well, it used to be me and Morgan, but now it's me, right? Talk about on Thursdays.
And the, against the Archon's name was just one that I came up with because we, our original name we
couldn't use. So I was trying to find something quickly that sort of, um, epitomized the subject
that we were talking about. And, um, yeah, I don't know. And so I, I had this guy, uh,
this dude listened to our original dream room space and he's, um, he's born again, Christian,
uh, as am I, uh, to, you know, and I, I don't make any secret about that. Although I'm not,
I'm not, um, evangelical. So he, uh,
he's got this whole thing where he's going after, um, or he's, he's writing about, uh,
demonic deception in the new age and Gnosticism and he's doing his thing. And I think it's positive
because he's bringing some awareness of, of some of the, I don't know. There's a lot of stuff that
happens in the, this community, the UFO community and the paranormal community. It's really ill-advised,
right? There are people who are talking to spirits and just things like some of them might be mental
health issues. And some of it is like in contact with real things, I believe, but they're not necessarily
good things. Right. And so when someone comes out and they're Christian, I think that's great.
When they come out in there, um, they're spreading awareness about the dangers and pitfalls in the,
and the new age and this, I don't know, this, um, counterfeit Gnosticism. The, the word Gnosticism
was originally applied as a, uh, uh, an insult to, um, a large percentage of the early Christian church
that, that held a different, a non-Orthodox set of beliefs. And, um, they were, they were wiped out over time.
Um, in the sixties, seventies, I guess the name, the term became popular again. The study became popular.
Um, there was a discovery of some texts, the Nag Hammadi library. Um, they discovered this text that
had these, uh, Gnostic works that had been believed to be permanently destroyed or permanently lost.
So, um, people started studying them again. They started writing books about them again. It became,
it became popular. And apparently like, um, a lot of, uh, a lot of new agey people sort of took the term
and appropriated it and appropriated it and appropriated the history and then went off in
some very strange directions. And so when you hear someone now, like particularly someone who's
anti-Gnostic talking about Gnosticism, you have no idea what they're talking about because it could be
anything. Um, and it's probably something very strange that has nothing to do with the original concepts.
Uh, which is the case with this one individual. And he, um, he apparently he listened to our doom room
and he wrote a book, uh, partially inspired by our doom room session. And he put a chapter in the book.
I haven't read it yet because when he told me about the book, he didn't tell me about the chapter
that was in there about me. Uh, and he didn't tell me it cost $26. Now, you know, $26 is not the end of
the world, but you know, someone says to you, Hey, I wrote a book. Do you want to read some of it?
Okay. Yeah, great. But it's not the same thing as saying, Hey, do you want to buy my book?
Right? So I was like, well, I'm not going to buy this guy's book. You know, the guy I talked to on
X a few times. And, uh, I only found out a couple of days ago that in fact has a chapter about me in
it, which would probably would have changed my, um, you know, probably would have changed the decision.
Um, and I guess the chapter he's telling me is about how, uh, as he was listening to the space, he,
he knew that demonic influences were trying to deceive us and convince us of, um, of a story,
the story that we were relating and it's so it's, it's such a complicated, right? Like it's such a
complicated story to tell. Cause you're talking about like a conversation you had with somebody else
about like spaces and ideas. And so it's hard to know where to begin. And it makes me even less
articulate than usual, but, uh, yeah, I mean, he doesn't, I don't think he completely trashed us.
I haven't seen it yet, but he basically did. And, um, there are definitely mental health,
right? Like his, his concept is that demons are deceiving us. Right? So that's beyond mental health.
Like he's, he thinks that there's, um, uh, non, uh, non-corporeal spirits actively trying to
convince us these things are true when they're not. Now, if I were to go to,
if something doesn't affect your life, you don't go to see someone, right? So you have people out there
who believe crazy things, but they're not crazy. Uh, just holding a belief or holding ideas or, or,
or, um, unless you're dealing with a real gaslighter therapist, you know, just, um,
entertaining ideas does not make, does not make it crazy. Even if they're like very, very, uh,
unusual ideas. Now you could say someone was paranoid, right? You could say like,
okay, you guys, uh, you, you have these ideas. Uh, it's, um, it's paranoia. One of the reasons that I,
I go to such great lengths whenever we talk about these subjects. Now I, whenever I talk about them
is to, um, establish the, the history, right? These are not new ideas.
These ideas are thousands of years old. Millions of people have believed them. And that's important
because it does change. Um, it changes the, the way that, uh, a third party can perceive what you're
saying. They might still think that your ideas sound paranoid, but it gives them more credence,
right? It's less like something just, just, uh, invented by a random crazy person. Cause they've
never heard of it before. They've never heard these ideas before. Um, so their ideas that a paranoid
person might have, but they don't make you paranoid to have them. It's important to establish that fact.
Uh, there's, um, especially, you know, anyone who's really dealt with somebody who is experiencing
extreme paranoia. It's a, it's a feeling that's overwhelming. It's a compulsion and it's something
you can sense from the person, right? Like you, you, you, you're talking to them and it's hard when
you're online because you're not looking at someone, but you're, if you're sitting across
from someone who's paranoid, you know, you can see it, you can hear it in their voice and you actually
get the feeling from just from being in their presence. You, you begin to get a little bit of
the same feeling that they're experiencing themselves. It's almost contagious.
Um, so the first thing you want to do when you talk about something like this
is establish the fact that, uh, even if someone thinks the idea is sound paranoid, you're not
paranoid or you may not be paranoid, right? Because they're going to believe what they want to believe.
And when you say like, this is an academic tradition going back thousands of years, okay,
that puts you in a, in a safer zone. Unless again, like I said, they're a gas lighter.
The next thing you got to deal with or you want to watch out for is, um,
when you're talking to someone and they have ideas like this, um, or unusual ideas,
you want to look for ideas or delusions of personal representation.
Everyone has ideas of personal representation at some point in their life. That's when you talk to
somebody and they say like, um, something happened on their birthday and wouldn't it be funny if there
was a connection or like they kind of imply that there's a connection between an event or something
that happened in their life and something that happened, um, something that happened in the world,
right? So it's not like a causative connection, but it's like, um, it's just an idea. Oh, like there's
an idea. There's a connection between something I saw on a license plate or someplace I was, and it has
uh, a larger meaning and connection with like world events or, um, something magical or, uh, something
involving UFOs. Okay. Everyone has those feelings. And, and I don't think that those feelings are always,
um, those ideas are always false, to be honest. But it's important to assess whether you have those ideas
or not and to what degree you have them because in times when you're starting to, to feel that if you do,
right, that can be a time when you're not doing as well psychologically.
I don't have ideas of personal, um, well, I guess not, not to a large degree.
Uh, and then there were delusions of personal representation and, um, a delusion of personal
representation is when you establish something like a, in your mind, you establish a causative
relationship between something that's occurring in your life and something that happens in the world
around you. Like I, um, I, you could say a person could say like they didn't follow their, uh, ritual.
And so their baseball team lost, they have a good luck ritual. And if they follow that ritual,
their baseball team wins. And if they don't, their baseball, and that, that's very common. So you
wouldn't put, you know, you wouldn't label someone as mentally ill if they had like that, but you would,
if they started to believe that their personal behavior was responsible for like global events
or events in the lives of, um, celebrities or, you know, anything like that. Now, again,
it's not the end of the world that someone develops that symptom, but it is a mental health symptom.
It's something that you find in, in people who experienced delusions.
Now, when you get into synchronicity, right, synchronicity is noticing something like that.
And so it's kind of dangerous because people who chase synchronicities inevitably start to develop
greater ideas of personal representation. And it's possible delusions of personal representation,
because you're saying like this, this, this cue occurs in my environment or in the media,
and it's connected to some meaning. And as opposed to saying like, where it gets dangerous is when you
start to say it's connected to something, it means something about me or oneself. So, um,
if a researcher believes that crop circles have a meaning and they very well may. Okay. But if they
believe that crop circles have a meaning, um, if they believe that synchronicity in their environment,
in the media can lead them to read specific, important, um, books or, um,
or make some sort of personal
leap in their, like meditation practice or the self-awareness,
that's not, that's not bad. That that's, that's perfectly in line with synchronicity.
Uh, and that's what Young invented it for. It's like, um, an external
indicator of an internal shift in the individual, right? Because we're all linked together through a
collective unconscious. But if you think that your actions determine the events or that the events
themselves are indicative of like the universe or something in the universe trying to tell you that
you're special, um, people who, uh, follow synchronicity sometimes get caught up in messiah
complexes, for instance. Like that's, that's a worrying mental health, uh, sign. Now, the reason I'm
talking about this is not because it's, I want to talk about mental health. And this is probably
going to be a short space, Melissa, because, um, I think it's just you and I right now. And again,
uh, you're, um, you know, you're very important. I don't want to just, uh, talk for an hour and a half.
Um, the other thing is, uh, X makes it difficult for me to see sometimes when there are or are not
people in the room. So sometimes it might be only one person or maybe half a dozen
people on icons on the screen, but it doesn't represent who's actually there.
And that's why it's difficult to make the decision. Um, you know, how short to cut the space.
Uh, so if, and if, as soon as you begin to feel like what I'm saying is boring, repetitive, redundant,
um, then you want to go, go ahead. Um, your icon may be on my screen until the end. Anyhow,
I might spend an hour talking to you and you might not even be here right now. Uh,
when the space is recorded,
other people can listen later, right? Not that I wouldn't talk to you for an hour. I would,
but what I'm saying is, is that if it sounds kind of bombastic, like I'm talking to an audience,
even though it's just you and I, it's, it's because there will be an audience, even if it's just a few
people, uh, later on when people listen to this. Um, so the reason I bring up those mental health,
uh, issues is that they, they occur, um, among both people who are, um, again,
not everyone who's a researcher in the paranormal experiences these. And if they do, they may only
experience them once in a while as like an occupational hazard and not as a mental health issue.
But people who, um, fall on the other side as well, people who fall into the, uh, playing the game of,
uh, trying to expose, um, any type of paranormal research as, um, as a non-human intelligence deception,
they experienced the same, um, predispositions for the same experiences
slash potential mental health system, uh, um, symptoms.
When people,
I believe in non-human intelligence and a lot of people do, if you're religious, you believe in
non-human intelligence, uh, more than likely. Um, if you, uh, are interested in UFOs,
you believe in non-human intelligence. If you're into the paranormal, you believe in non-human intelligence.
So a lot of people do, uh, more I think than don't, but the way our media, um, crafts things
to try to make people with unusual ideas, um, or ideas that are unusual from their perspective seem
crazy, um, always sort of diminishes the number of people hold ideas. A lot of people believe in ghosts,
for instance, right? Um, so in this case, uh, if you believe that, uh, demonic forces
are trying to deceive people, um, through new age, um, modalities, through new age, um,
behaviors or belief systems, they're probably right. I think some cases they're absolutely right.
I think that people who, um, who channel the council of nine of Ra council of 12 council of Saturn,
like I, I, that's, that's a huge red flag for me. People channel, it's a huge red flag, but, um,
specifically people who channel like groups of benevolent extraterrestrials with a message.
Um, that's, that's very, uh, very concerning to me and people who,
we get into it. Uh, that concerns me. People take it very seriously. That concerns me
because, you know, just because you have a feeling and you hear something or have an experience, a hallucination or,
um, whatever it is, right. It doesn't mean it's positive just because you have a,
what do you have a feeling? It felt like a good voice or it sounded like a good voice.
Um, that, that, that's very concerning. Um, it could be anything. It very well could be some form of deception.
I would believe it would be if you were having that experience more than likely.
Um, but to have the belief that, um, to have the belief that a lot of the world is being orchestrated
in order to deceive you, right? That, that's a little paranoid, if not a lot of paranoid,
depending on how you feel about it. And it definitely involves, um, delusional
thinking related to ideas, if not delusions of personal representation.
So you have to be kind of, if you, if you are a paranormal investigator researcher,
if you are interested, interested in synchro mysticism and esoteric mystical doctrines that involve
synchronicity and, you know, signs in the world around you studying them, you have to always be
careful. You have to assess yourself, uh, to make sure that your, your thinking isn't being
affected by what you're doing the same way. Someone who uses AI has to do a lot of self-assessment now
because it's actually, it's actually very, very similar, uh, because of the, the feedback. Um,
but if you are trying to reveal, um, the deception that you think people are being exposed to, if you're
hearing other people talk about their, I don't know, whatever it is that they're, they're, they're
reiki or their yoga or whatever, and, and you think they're subject to demonic, um, influence.
Uh, once you get to the point where you believe, they're not just, you know, their dreams, because
that's this, what this guy is saying is he's saying, you know, um, demons orchestrate, um,
out-of-body experiences. Probably true, uh, in a sense. I mean, archons, uh, demon is, uh, is a newer term.
Uh, then skip to, well, dreams, dreams are orchestrated by non-human intelligence. Well,
I mean, that's more troublesome, right? Because now you've got like an entire, um,
like you, you've got a lot of energy going into, uh, deceiving and manipulating people
when they're sleeping in that, in that case. Uh, and then from that, you would move forward and say,
like, synchronicities are intentional deception. Well, now you believe that there's like, um,
you're starting to have these, uh, uh, ideas of, of delusions of personal representation that
the, the world events are being shaped, um, for your benefit or in order to manipulate you in some way.
And what we've run into since we started talking about this, we've run into people who,
you know, it's very important for them to prove that what we're saying is, is a deception.
But in order to do so, they're willing to posit that history, the historical record
that backs up what we're saying was, is false, is, is a deception.
That historical, mystical, clairvoyant communities were also deceived.
That, uh, people who experienced synchronicities around the subject and people who have,
you know, um, a personal belief in the, in these subjects, they were deceived for thousands of years.
Political systems have been altered, um, in order to further this deception.
Um, including things like UFO retrieval programs and, um, the CIA and the Pentagon.
Uh, and then you get to the, the point where, when you point out, um,
synchronicities occurring in the world with things like technology, right?
You, you get to the point where people are willing to believe that events in the world
are being orchestrated to deceive a few, if not one person.
And if you're coming from the perspective of, like, say, evangelical Christianity, and, and you're looking
at everything that's non-evangelical as new age, then you're saying that the world
is being manipulated in order to convince individuals, um, that modern evangelical beliefs aren't true
or aren't exactly accurate.
And at that point, number one, you're not disproving the whole simulation concept because
clearly we're in a simulation.
If everything from our dreams to the events that happen in the world are being personally catered
or altered in order to, to, to manipulate us.
Um, so you're, you're, that's, boy, am I on a, just a ramble.
This is the worst one.
I was supposed to write everything down, Melissa.
And of course I didn't, I didn't get much sleep last night as usual.
And so I'm just rambling, uh, leaving this, this recording is a disaster.
Thank you for being here.
I always appreciate you being here.
So it seems that the archetypes, um, I'm going to start over and I appreciate you being here.
The concept of, um, a resistance to the archons and organized resistance to the archons is an
emerging archetype.
It seems that this archetype has been emerging from the collective unconscious for about 20 years.
It's been like the trail is longer than that.
And like I said, even goes back to, to antiquity, but it seems that this archetype has been emerging
in popular culture, um, for about 20 years.
It's, it's uncomfortable for people to talk about this subject, the subject of, uh, archetypes emerging into,
um, speculative fiction.
We can talk about the Simpsons predicted things, which is exactly the same thing.
When you say like events are predicted in the Simpsons cartoon, you're saying that emergent archetypes
are appearing in, in the form of, uh, cartoon television shows.
Right.
They're popping up through the collective unconscious.
And that's how it happens because writers and artists, uh, are able to bypass the filters
in their brains.
In all of our brains, we have a filter.
This is a metaphor, right?
We have a filter that, um, sort of weeds out unusual ideas and perceptions from normal ones.
But artists are able to circumvent those filters without losing their minds, without being crazy.
And so what would otherwise be, um, perceptions that were only available to psychics, uh, show up all the
time in popular fiction.
It makes people uncomfortable because there's a strong taboo around taking, um,
taking extreme imagery from popular fiction, uh, seriously.
It's the taboo is that if you are seriously trying to analyze archetypes in fiction, then you're crazy.
And the best example I can give, um, are zombies.
Uh, obviously like it was a time in the eighties, seventies and eighties when zombie movies started
to come out and then they just sort of accelerated more and more zombie movies.
And it sort of peaked in the nineties and the first decade of 2000.
Around 2011, I was part of some groups that were involved in examining archetypes and the paranormal
online and I was trying to bring up the, um, what, what might be the collective meaning
for this increasing number of, uh, zombie television shows and movies.
Like what, what was the collective unconscious trying to tell us all, not as individuals, but as a collective,
as a historical precedent for this, because, um, prior to enduring the black death,
uh, there was a, a movement in art that involved, um, uh, painting these dance, I'm going to screw
this up because I can't even pronounce English, dance macabre, uh, paintings of, uh, peasants
dancing with skeletons. It was like this whole thing, but it emerged prior to the black death. And from the
study of archetypes, one would say that that emerging archetype, the dance macabre predicted
where it wasn't just an expression of the anxieties of artists during the time of the black death, but it
was, it was predictive. The, the, the archetype, the sense of what was coming emerged first in art.
So I, from that perspective, I wanted to look into the zombie stuff and nobody would even respond.
Nobody would even acknowledge that I was posting the questions because the, the taboo was so strong.
Now, to me, this question has been answered since because when we had the lockdowns,
the first lockdowns, we're heading into a second set of lockdowns, right? I think lockdowns are the
full emergence of the archetype into the collective conscious. I think that, um, if you look at, uh,
zombie shows, whatever people focus on the, the disease the humans have or the way they're acting,
but the archetype itself is the environment. So if you were out in a major city during the lockdowns
and you were looking around the streets, everyone said the same thing. This is just like a horror movie
and meaning like a zombie apocalypse film. And that's what I believe the imagery was anticipating.
That authors, writers, directors, um, were, uh, were accessing these images coming out of the collective
unconscious, uh, because there is no time, uh, in the collective unconscious, right? Just like there is
no time in the psychic world. It's the same thing. It's the same place. What Jung called the Unus Mundi,
the one world that we can't perceive, um, that these ideas come from. And they, they are predictive.
Jung talked about them being predictive when he was talking about his theories a hundred years ago.
So, uh, the, the stuff we talk about in Against the Archons, as odd as it is,
is, is, is part of an emerging archetype. And that emerging archetype really started to accelerate
about 20 years ago, um, through this lit RPG fiction, Dungeon Core, they call it.
I think you'll probably find it in comic books. Uh, again, it's ridiculous and uncomfortable to talk
about sometimes the reason that these subjects are able to find expression in that taboo art is,
is because it's taboo, right? It's like something that kids would pay attention to,
or people who are a little different would pay attention to it. And you're not supposed to pay
attention to it when you're part of like mainstream, normal adult society.
And that novelty allows the artist to suspend the filter that keeps these ideas, you know, the,
the social consciousness that keeps them from expressing these ideas and images.
So as this Dungeon Core, uh, starts to develop, it focuses around the idea of, um, simulation theory.
Now, simulation theory is supposedly only like 20 years old. That's not true.
Um, we were talking about in the nineties, but if you look into it, like online simulation theory,
they'll say Nick, um, Bach, Bachstrom, uh, I'm getting his name screwed up too. They'll give you like
a, um, a specific individual and it'll be like within the last 20 years that the idea was formulated.
But, um, Bill K. Dick was talking about like, are we living in a computer simulation in the seventies?
So, and I, I do remember having conversations about it in the nineties.
But that idea, uh, emerged into fiction as the idea that we are against our will being subject to some
some sort of game and we're not in a game, but, um, that is how it emerged into, um, popular art.
What we're concerned about is that the exact details, right? The exact details that we discuss
that we found in the IU session data and then went back and found in historical session data and in the
session data of other, uh, remote viewers, which to recap involve, um, political prisoners being right.
It's a, it's a storyline that involves a simulation created from political prisoners or as part of an
unethical medical experiment involving political prisoners, um, wherein through the use of technology,
the simulation is created in their minds. And the experiment itself is, uh, powered by
the energy of their soul or spirit. So that, that's what people see. And that is
what makes it different from simulation theory. And it's, it is those very details that have emerged up
through this, um, this type of literature, um, which against began with people who are, were artistic or
somewhat artistic who, um, wanted to pretend to be in a video game or, or read about, read stories where they
pretend that people are in the video game. So that provided the metaphor, which allowed this information
to come through. As we started having this conversation, right? Like in, uh, 2019, I had a serious accident.
Um, in 2021, I wanted to know if I would be able to, if I would be able to do anything notable.
Or important. Now that I was disabled. I hired a remote viewer to look into my optimal, um, career path.
And, uh, that remote viewer said, Hey, if you're interested in remote viewing information, uh,
you got to take a look at, uh, this group that I'm involved in intuitive underground. I read their material.
I found it disquieting, um, upsetting, but I couldn't quite put my finger on why.
Um, as a side note, the remote viewer, um, the roving material, uh, about my ideal career path.
Um, the remote viewer, um, the remote viewer continued to have this imagery that I was inside
some sort of machine, which is very interesting because the major development of my life since then
has been stumbling upon this information and coming up with the idea that and talking to people about
the idea that, you know, we are in a, um, a form of reality overlay, right? A form of simulation.
So that was actually in that removing data. He didn't know what to make of it.
And, uh, he took away from it that maybe I should work in a high school audio visual department or
something, which doesn't sound like it sounds like sort of very odd, but how else was he supposed to
understand that data? He, he, he didn't have any connection with these ideas or at least in that,
in that context. So, uh, 2020, uh, sorry. Yeah. So I read the, uh, um, intuitive underground material.
I see one of the remote viewers, his name is Morgan Farrell and something just clicked. And I said,
Morgan Farrell is, is the guy I should be talking to. But I thought he lived in New Zealand for some
strange reason, maybe because his name was Morgan. And, um, I didn't have any way to contact him.
I didn't want to just send him a cold message and say, Hey, this is weird, but you know,
I want to talk to you about this IU material. Cause it's something that I can't understand about it.
It makes me a little uncomfortable. Um, 2023, I notice, uh, Morgan's
X account and I follow him and he follows me. And then I, we just sort of converge. And it's clear that,
um, this individual is paying attention to my,
my posts for some reason. And it turns out, uh, eventually that somehow he had identified me as an
individual he wanted to work with on the Astro RV project. I wound up being a consultant on the Astro RV
project. Um, the first experiment on how to, uh, utilize the two in order to, um, successfully
predict future events, which is an ongoing project, but it seems to have fizzled out at the moment.
Other people sort of taking up the project. It's going to be big in the future. Anyways.
Uh, that's 2023, uh, end of 2024. I go back, I revisit the material for the third time IU material
and everything just sort of clicks into place. And I realized what it is about the material that evaded
the analysis evaded Morgan's analysis and his, his fellow's analysis. So I contact him at the end of
uh, 2024 and I said, look, here's the deal, right? Like you're analyzing this material, but
this is what I think you're not, you don't want to see. And I think that, you know, I've looked into
other remote viewers who've looked into this material and everyone who does, it seems to develop some
sort of like post-traumatic stress. They leave RV, they stop talking about it, the sessions they repudiate,
uh, or sorry, repudiate those particular sessions. Um, and I think that there's something like the, the,
the idea is so disturbing that it's difficult for people to, uh, admit or promote what they're seeing.
And that is that the, um, you know, the reality overly operates on biological hardware, right? That's,
it's operating, um,
the brain cells are being used as a computer basically. And the,
it seems that whether it's dreams or our waking life, um, a certain extent of that is like, uh,
it's something that they do in computers with a computer rests. It runs like some sort of like, um,
little program that's, it's like, it's computer downtime program. I don't know what it's called.
I have to figure that out for the next time because I've really made a mess of this space.
Uh,
so as we're, we're having that discussion, I've been playing this game with some friends.
We get to the end of the game and the revelation at the end of the game, like the same week that I
have this discussion with Morgan. It's like very emotional cause it's very like sort of disturbing
um, topic. And it's also one that's like hard to talk about. So we finally talk about it and we're
like, Oh shit, that's what it means. And then, you know, the day, two days later, I'm playing the game
and the end of the game, the final scene of the game is the revelation, right? Of, of basically what
we were just talking about. Like the game setting is, is pretty much identical to the story that we
identified in the IU session data. Um,
those synchronicities continued. Now synchronicities in and of themselves are not,
people take them the wrong way. As I, as I said earlier, they,
they, uh, attach personal significance. Like the fact that they're experiencing the synchronicity
means there's something special about them or like they've been chosen or something as opposed to
just, you could look at a synchronicity is a treasure map. It's a treasure map. That's been
lying there waiting for someone to find it. Right. And you just happen to be the person who sets off or
opens the map, sets off the, um, um, I'm using gamer speak. So, uh, yeah, you're the person who sees the
map, right? And that doesn't mean that, um, the universe is created for you. It means that you just
happen to find something that's waiting there for people who are looking for it.
To the best of my knowledge, we're the only ones who have really drilled into or drilled down into this
archetype that being emergent in popular media. And it was me, it wasn't Morgan.
And just like when we're trying to, uh, or when I was trying to talk, um, about the zombie thing
years ago, the zombie archetype, uh, in an intellectual or academic way, and nobody wanted anything to do
with it because it was taboo like this being from, um, like gaming media and gaming related media is,
is also a taboo subject.
However, if as this, uh, this guy, uh, Seth, um,
it wouldn't be enough to say that we were being deceived, that the remote viewers were being
deceived in this session data, or that we were being deceived in our dreams, or that
the order of events in our lives had been reorganized or had been orchestrated in some way to lead us to have
these beliefs.
Because in order for these synchronicities to be possible,
this material had to be out in media in order to have a synchronicity where you're having a
conversation about something and then the big reveal of the game you're playing is the same.
Now that's just one, that's just one example, right? Because it turns out
that these ideas are like completely saturating speculative media. So there's a television show
called, uh, Fallout, which is very popular, very good show, by the way. And it's based on a game
and the game's been around since the nineties. It's like on its eighth and ninth iteration.
And they made a show out of it. And we just went through the third season of the show.
Pretty sure it's the third season. And the big reveal of the third season
was that they're creating this reality overlay and it's being run out of a mainframe. And when they
get to the mainframe, it's, it's a person's head, it's the person's brain.
The same thematic ideas, um, the same story basically. And that,
that, that game line, that, uh, game narrative has been around since the 1990s.
It's, you can look at it as random and it's certainly
novel. But in order to believe that events like that are designed specifically to manipulate
a few people or one person,
you're now talking about the idea that reality itself has been altered in a long-term plan
so that one day somebody who's interested in remote viewing will get the idea right from the remote
viewing. And then the experience of the game, the movie, the television show, the book,
and that will manipulate them into believing what a non-human intelligence wants them to believe.
You can say it's weird to see the synchronicity.
And if somebody had obsessed about it, you could say they were paranoid.
But it is absolutely crazy to say, right, that 20, 30 years of history
had been orchestrated so that a few guys, one of them a remote viewer, or a couple remote viewers,
and a person who's interested in remote viewing, would be manipulated and deceived into believing
that modern evangelical Christianity isn't exactly right. And that's crazy. That is delusions
of personal representation, and I guess delusions of the representation of people around you.
We, those synchronicities became fairly common. And again, like, it's a mistake to put too much,
it's a mistake to put personal meaning to them. They're just like, um,
a notable event. You talk like, oh, okay, wow, that's, that's weird, huh? But you don't obsess
about them. You don't fixate on them. You don't, you know, you absolutely never develop the belief
that they're an indication that, like, you know, they're there just for you. It's just like finding
a treasure map. It's just like finding an old book. Um, but what we've discovered is,
as we recognize, right, or around the same time that we're recognizing this
technology in the remote viewing data, session data,
that something related to that technology is emerging into the popular consciousness. That's how
emergent archetypes work, right? They, they boil up from the collective unconscious.
Um, they will end up in, in psychic session data, but they'll also end up in,
in books, comic books, video games, any type of novel, speculative fiction.
And then as they sort of break into the collective consciousness, as opposed to the collective
unconscious, right, they're emergent. And through that process of emergence, which precedes the change
in the environment, you will then see technological advances or social advances
that correlate with that emergent archetype. That has nothing to do with the individuals evolved,
except that they happen to see it.
This is how the collective unconscious communicates to us. This is basic Jungian psychology.
So, um,
the best example that I can give is around the time we started to, uh, give spaces talking about this and,
and the hypothetical, um, you know, hypothetically we're saying the remote viewing session data might
indicate that, you know, there is a simulation, but instead of being a simulation inside of a computer,
it's a simulation inside of a, a group of networked physical brains, right? And using neurological material
as opposed to circuits. And so in a sense, it is a collective dream. This, the same way into, you know, um,
Aboriginal civilizations and religions and civilizations in antiquity said it would be right around that time.
Uh, a company in Australia started marketing computers that ran on human brain cells.
We've shown these in spaces. We've shown these in, uh, our discord group. They're for sale.
You can Google it. They cost 35 grand. They taught them to teach. They taught them to play Pong
in late 2024, early 2025. And they were just in the news again, two weeks ago,
because they taught them to play Doom, which is ironic, um, in many ways that the choice of that game
is ironic in many ways. So the technology that we're talking about now exists physically. It didn't
before we started talking about it. That doesn't mean it didn't before I started talking about it. It
doesn't mean it didn't before Morgan started talking about it. That's not what I mean. I mean,
it didn't before people started talking about it, uh, before it broke into the collective consciousness
from the art. It could have been Doomer. It could have been, I'm just picking random names, red panda
quality, uh, Logan short stack or whatever. Um, could have been popular politicians. It could have
been, it could have been anybody who recognized that archetype, started talking about it right at the
time and emerge because that's how it works. So to speculate that, um, well, to, um, the best series of
audio books of all time, Dungeon Crawler Carl, uh, the way, the reason that I, I specifically cite that
example is that I started listening to Dungeon Crawler Carl around the same time following my accident.
I started listening to audio books. I found the Dungeon Crawler Carl series. It was suggested to
me because I was listening to lit RPG dungeon core books. I started listening to them because they're
entertaining and also because I had been through a traumatic traumatic brain injury and I needed
to listen to something that, how do I put this? Uh, I couldn't handle great literature, right? I
couldn't handle great literature and I couldn't handle like really super intellectual stuff for years.
after the accident, it took me time to get back. I'm still not where I was, but like, it took me years
to get back to the point where I could focus on things like, you know, very, um, technical concepts.
So, uh, started listening to the, the, the, um, Dungeon Crawler Carl, it starts off with like, um,
it's almost like Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy. It starts off with aliens arriving and wiping out
civilization and turning the planet into a, uh, a dungeon, um, slash reality TV show for the galaxy.
Um, so the surviving human beings have to compete in this dungeon for the entertainment of the galaxy. This
is the storyline. It develops as the years go on and that development parallel these ideas breaking
through the remote human community and becoming something we talked about in like spaces or online,
breaking through the taboo. Some of us, obviously majority of human beings would still experience
extreme taboo having this discussion. Uh, and it turns out by the time he gets to book seven
that the details that he'd always planned for the series, um, like, uh, the, the truth that they discover,
right? Those details are the same or very similar to, um, that, you know, uh, uh, but the planet is an AI.
It's a nascent AI, uh, growing in the planet and every human being on the planet has a, a little tiny
point in their, in their brains that records the feelings of their lives. And that energy is then used
to power the AI when they die. But the system, the reality TV show, uh, manipulates that system.
Again, the, the exact details, unless you listen to it, aren't, aren't really important, except to say
that it, it's yet another variation, the same themes, you know, including the, the thing with the brain,
uh, the neuro neurological tissue, uh, that we find emerging sort of everywhere in speculative fiction
and, and through the remote viewing data. So even if, if the, the, the,
this critic who wrote a chapter of a book about me being influenced by non-human intelligence,
if he was correct, right? And part of that influence, right? That influence would be
not just the, the ancient Gnostic literature. So there'd be thousands of years of literature
written to manipulate people like me. It wouldn't just be the remote viewing session data.
Right. And it wouldn't just be the emerging technology coming out right after we find this information
through remote viewing and through, you know, reading the, the novel speculative fiction. Right.
So it's like we get involved, we're being manipulated by the sessions, hypothetically. Right. We're being
manipulated by the historical data. Then we're being manipulated by the, the actual technology we're
talking about showing up and being produced in real life, but also the fiction that I've been reading for years
and, um, um, other fictional series like Fallout, uh, Doctor Who, um, you know, many of the
most popular science fiction series, uh, have this, these very ideas at their core.
Um, that you only discover when you've, you, you've been listening and paying attention for a long time. So
even like the, the media, the, the fiction would have been manipulated years in advance
by non-human intelligence. If this, if this person was right, if this theory was right,
just so that at this point in time, people like myself, mostly myself, right? I can't even see people
like myself because it mostly would be me and Morgan and Dan, um, of all the people on planet earth.
Because imagine that, imagine, imagine if effort like that was put in to, uh, to create this
manipulation just so, um, I would be deceived or, and Morgan and Dan would be deceived.
I mean, that, that's like the strongest idea of personal representation I can think of,
but it's in someone else's mind about me, right? And, and that's crazy.
That's a person who's, who's being deceived by their ideology to believe that the world has
been orchestrated to convince me, right? A fat disabled guy in Massachusetts who's having a wonderful,
you know, who's, who's rambling on, you know, uh, for, for one very, very nice person who always shows up for his
spaces. Just imagine that the unbelievable and narcissistic ego that, that someone would have
to believe that about themselves, but then to project that on somebody else, right? Like, it's
not that I disagree. It's not that I have reasons to disagree. Right? The only reason that I don't
understand that his belief system is literally true, that he has discovered
the literal truth of the universe, the literal truth of the universe. The only reason that I don't believe
that and know that is because in his mind of this elaborate, grandiose, mystical, spiritual, demonic
conspiracy that has altered reality all over the place in order to deceive me.
Those are the type of arguments that we come up against from people who desperately want to say
that everything that we've discovered has been a deception.
The,
the mental gymnastics, the delusional thinking, the, frankly, paranoia, okay? And not that people have
sort of a right to be paranoid about subjects like this, to be honest. I don't, I don't really ever
feel paranoid, but people have a right to, you know, be paranoid when they start thinking about
things like this, when they start learning about it. Okay. But all of that focused,
you know, towards me and what I'm trying to say, that's an incredible opposition.
And the, you know, the irony is, is that I'm a Christian. No, I'm not a good Christian.
Right? But nothing I've ever said, and I, and every time I give one of these things, right, I stop by saying,
I am not, I am not, I am not contradicting
historical Christian teachings. I definitely am not on the same page with modern middle American evangelicals.
Or, you know, modern Catholic teachings or whatever. Okay.
But the basic tenets of Christianity, absolutely, I say right from the beginning, I have no intention of
contradicting. I don't look at it as either, or I look at it as an and.
And I look at this as, as stuff that follows from those events and not evidence that those events
didn't occur. I very much believe they did. But because of the, right, the stuff that we think,
you know, or we find that everyone who has like psychic ability sees, or that's recorded historically,
or that is popping up through our media, or that is now emerging into the real world through actual
technology. You know, the fact that this archetype, this against the archons archetype, this idea of a,
of a group of people resisting, you know, the archons, um, in just in a number of different ways,
but there's this, this like small community of people who are aware of, of the historical
and, and modern conception of, of, of, of the archons, like the existence of the community, not us as
individuals, but this emergent archetype about the existence of a community, uh, is so threatening
that and creates such cognitive dissonance that an individual I've never met in Florida
will write a book about the evidence that the world has been, you know, orchestrated in order
to specifically deceive me. Now, I'm not the only one. He's got a whole list of people, right? But
because we're all deceived differently in different ways, the only way that would be possible is if
history and the world and other people's lives had been intentionally orchestrated to deceive us
each as individuals. So it's not like it would only be me. It would be like a list of people who all had
global astral conspiracies that orchestrated human lives and media and, oh, I mean, I'm actually worse
this time. Articulate, I'm, it's more difficult for me to articulate this time because it's, it's so
overwhelming to think about, um, so no one should listen to something that I say and believe it based
on the fact that I'm saying it. Everyone should say, okay, he's saying that this subject is, is, is
articulated in ancient literature, ancient Gnostic texts. Let's look at the texts. He's saying that it's
found in esoteric texts, you know, throughout the period since antiquity. Let's look at those texts,
right? Um, he's saying that it's found in the, the archetype itself is emerging through popular media
and it's found in speculative fiction. You know, when did this, these stories start coming out in
science fiction? You know, when did they start appearing in games? When did they start appearing in
you know, whatever, and movies? And then, you know, is the, are these ideas
emerging more? Like is, is, are these archetypes spreading in fiction? Are there more movies and
more stories and more TV shows? And then are these technologies emerging into the, what we consider to
be the real world, into our waking reality, right? Like when this stuff began to show up in, in media
or in remote viewing sessions, was it possible to, to build a computer,
right? That their hardware was, was human brain cells, was cloned, replicated human brain cells.
It wasn't, right? So how many of these, these perceptions, these technologies, these perceptions,
the technologies and these perceptions, like how many of them were predicted
in, in that media or in those remote viewing sessions that are now real? Because if you're going to say,
well, it's a deception to think that that's possible. Well, it's now possible, right? So clearly it
wasn't a deception to think that it was possible for, uh, for people to build, uh, computers that ran on
human brain cells, because it's not possible. So if, if it started tomorrow, right? Like they have these,
they have these, it's horrible. It's absolutely horrible. It's so gothic that they have these little boxes,
um, which show up by the way, in the remote viewing years before. So I'm not, I don't want to articulate,
this isn't, this isn't a, uh, space about the, about the cube of Saturn and the little boxes. Um,
like they've got these, these little boxes, they've got a brain that they designed in the little box
that is now playing video games, right? For that brain with no sensory input, those video games are
the only real thing. Those brains are experiencing a simulation playing doom. So someone who tells me
that I have been deceived, that it is possible that our reality could be the, you know, something
far more elaborate based on the same principles, right, completely denying the fact that this is now
something that scientists in our waking reality are doing. And they weren't doing it when we started
talking about it. So I recommend Dungeon Crawler, Carl. It's a great series of books.
And, uh, I recommend people pay attention to popular media and these ideas like the,
the fallout series, uh, I think was on Amazon. I think it's on Amazon and, um, you know, how this
30 year old franchise, the story has continued to change until it's, its ultimate, um, revelation
is that this is all something that's going on in a person's mind.
Right. In the, in their brain, that this brain has been wired up to a machine like that's pay
attention to that stuff popping out of the, um, popping out of the collective unconscious into
the collective conscious that this emergence and, and then people need to make their own decisions,
I guess, about what they think is likely or unlikely. I know the most unlikely thing in the universe to me
is that the entire universe has been crafted in order to deceive me personally.
Right. I'm not saying that there aren't deceptions. I'm not saying that I haven't been deceived. I,
you know, I'm not God. I don't know, but I would be God or something close to it. I would believe that
about myself. If I believe that, uh, human history, at least in the last 20 years have been
crafted in order to deceive me personally. I don't believe that I'm not crazy.
So, um, that's what this was about. This archetypes and, you know, fallout doctor who,
uh, dungeon crawler, Carl dungeon core, um, lit RPG.
You're going to see it more and more because it's emerging. You're going to see the archetype coming
out in more television shows. You're going to see it coming out in more literature. You're going to
see it popping up everywhere. It's like a nine 11. Um, if you remember, because they're pretty much
everyone who listens to these spaces is old enough to remember nine 11. Uh, when nine 11 happened,
right? The government wheeled out a bunch of people who said, we never, nobody ever could have
imagined planes hitting the world trade center. And everyone thinks, well, it's a proof of conspiracy
because so many people had imagined planes hitting the world trade center, but no
that, that image was very popular in media books and television shows, right? Album covers,
but that's it. It was all novel, speculative fiction, science fiction, television shows,
rock and roll, heavy metal album covers, right? Things that the individuals like these government
bureaucrats, the president and his administration at that time, none of them had ever seen that stuff.
None of them had ever watched those television shows. None of them had ever seen those album
covers to them. They could say with a straight face that no one had ever imagined playing in the world
trade center because as a straight laced person, they blocked all that off. They didn't take it
seriously. Right. Just like right now, people will say like, there's a taboo around saying, Hey,
this stuff is popping up in games. It's popping up in books. It's probably popping up in comic books.
It's popping up in television and stuff. And that's meaningful from the perspective of our typical
analysis, right? That's the same with, with the bureaucrats post 9/11 where they, they, they would
have no idea that meaningful information could come through that because that was completely taboo for
them. They wouldn't even imagine paying attention to that type of media. All right. Well, Melissa,
I don't know if you're here or not because my phone wouldn't show me if you left. Um,
I don't know if other people are here or not because it probably wouldn't show me if anyone
arrived. Um, but I, I appreciate you showing support like this. Um, and you know, if you hadn't arrived,
I wouldn't have, uh, rambled on. I think that, uh, Oh, Hey, I think, I think you just put an emoji or
something great. That means you're here. Um, uh, the first half an hour, I'm probably going to edit
out because I was complete junk. I was just rambling, uh, cause I was upset about, I mean, not upset,
not happy, right? Not angry, not like sad or anything, just kind of frustrated that people snipe at each
other. Um, that everyone is here just to make statements and not to learn and listen.
And you don't get to the point where you have all these, like, you know, the reason I, I, I am able
to talk about all these subjects is I listened to people. I wouldn't be able to talk about it.
Otherwise I didn't vent any of this stuff. Some of it, I mean, you know, a small percentage of it,
most of it is material. I've learned from talking to other people, reading and listening to them,
but also just talking to them and listening to what they had to say. And, um, just, everyone is just
waiting to, uh, to use other people, um, to advance their own ideas. You know, I'm, I can't say that I
haven't been, I don't feel like I'm, I'm deceived by non-human intelligence, but I, who knows, right?
But certainly to diminish everything that I've, I've said and, and, and done to just, um, some kind
of cosmic circus aimed at manipulating me, that's, that's upsetting. Um, and then he was, uh, he wasn't
very, uh, polite about it. He was, he was okay. He wasn't that bad. Uh, but he definitely wasn't,
you know, it wasn't a bad conversation, but it definitely wasn't a great conversation either.
So, uh, thank you for, um, coming, Melissa. And, uh, I'm back again tomorrow to talk about,
uh, when, um, you know, I've been doing the spaces about, uh, Saturn and Neptune and the conjunction
and how important that is on a global level and how it's a, the most important conjunction
of our lives. Um, I'm not a Vedic astrologer, but I, I do follow Vedic astrology for a reason
that I'll explain, uh, tomorrow. And, um, I wanted to compare and contrast and see how,
like what they view as being the most important astrological event of this year could connect with
what I've been saying or might contradict what I've been saying in Western astrology,
you know, just sort of comparing and contrasting. Um, yeah, we'll see if anyone, uh, if anyone's
interested. Right. So, uh, okay. I'm going to end the space now and, um, I will, I'm sure I'll see you
again soon and, uh, thank you very much again for coming.